по-перше Секретар Ради нацбезпеки
оборони нічого не бачив сліпе як Кріт як
то називається А окрім того згадайте оцю
його заявочку що він передягнувся в
Чорне Тому треба було знати що війна а
мені би хотілося от публічно йому
сказати що безпека і оборона - це не
ветеринарія яку в якій він отримав
освіту і безпека оборона - це не зайчики
які міняють шкурку там з сірої на білу і
з білої на сіру Тому по-перше це а
некомпетентна на мою думку людина тому
що він мав би відповісти за оці всі свої
слова і небачення загроз вторнення а
друге якщо він не бачить опозиції Ну то
то скажемо так це є проблема всієї
держави що в нас є дуже багато людей які
поки їх Особисто не торкнеться не бачать
проблеми які є а опозиція є і опозиція є
дуже конструктивна Якщо наша влада не
здатна її бачити конструктивну опозицію
то в нас є проблеми з Владою